und plötzlich bricht das Inferno los
ukrainische Truppen gelingt ein heftiger
Treffer an der Front ein russischer
mehrfacher kettenwerfer Typ bm21 Grad
Kaliber 122 mm steht in einer
vermeintlich sicheren Stellung neben
einem Wäldchen eingebuddelt auf einem
Acker doch gegen die präzisionslenkwaffe
der Ukraine hat der Raketenwerfer keine
Chance wird zerstört
verwendet worden ist dabei wohl
Exkalibur Munition Munition die über dem
Ziel explodiert und durch tödliche
Schrapnelle alles durchlöchert diese
NATO Munition jetzt Excalibur zum ersten
Mal in der Ukraine eingetroffen ist so
genau dass sie tatsächlich mit jedem
Schuss ganz genau ihr Ziel trifft und
eigentlich fast gar nicht daneben geht
eine Drohne beobachtet den Vorgang aus
der Luft wohl in der Nähe von Wuhle da
Bild Militärexperten ordnen die Bilder
als echt und aktuell ein
durch die Zerstörung feiert der mehrfach
Raketenwerfer unkontrolliert noch zwei
Einheiten ab ist danach aber nicht mehr
einsatzfähig ein empfindlicher Treffer
gegen Putin Soldaten die wieder einen
leistungsstarken mehrfach Raketenwerfer
im Süden der Ukraine verlieren und
dessen tödliche Geschosse nicht mehr auf
Ukraine abgefeuert werden können